cameron was the ultimate example of a
human being
dove Cameron is still mourning the loss
of her descendants co-star Cameron Boyce
the actor died unexpectedly at the age
of 20 earlier this month
his life indescribable energy now dove
is encouraging fans to honor her friends
passion for philanthropy sharing this
pic on Instagram with the caption part
of the pain of the incredible grief we
are all experiencing after the loss of
Cameron is this communal sense of
heartbreak over all the good he has done
and all the good he was planning to do
he was selfless and generous
he was magnanimous in arguably a true
philanthropist at only 20 the 23 year
old added we truly lost one of the
world's best souls but if there is any
beauty in any of this we will find it in
picking up where Cameron left off dov
included a link to the Cameron boys
foundation writing quote this is how we
keep him alive this is how we feel him
every day in everything we do
booboo Stewart also asked fans to donate
posting this pic with a quote from his
descendants co-star we all go what you
leave should be bigger than you the late
actor's father announced the launch of
the foundation just days after his
passing according to the site the
Foundation provides young people
artistic and creative outlets as
alternatives to violence and negativity
and uses resources and philanthropy for
positive change in the world dove who
appeared with Cameron in three
descendants movies don't you ever miss
screaming at people and just making them
run away from you you're thinking of my
mother and I was usually on the other
end of that so not really know
previously opened up about her grief
three days after Cameron died from a
seizure in his sleep and he was
undoubtedly
the most talented person most of us will
ever know but what was special about
Cameron
was it who he was in his small moments
when maybe no one was looking the
moments in between the big ones when he
didn't have to be good or kind
Cameron was always cutting